on peut s'en étonner mais à l'occasion
du procès de maurice papon ne parle donc
pas seulement de son action pendant
l'occupation les témoins évoquent vous
l'avez entendu également son attitude
pendant la guerre d'algérie et notamment
lorsque préfet de paris le 17 octobre
1961 il était en titre le responsable de
la police à l'occasion de la tragique
manifestation organisée par le fln qui
se termina dans un bain de sang philippe
boisserie éric masson jamais mohamed
soussi qui n'oubliera ce 17 octobre 1961
ils voulaient manifester contre le
couvre-feu imposé aux algériens et pour
l'algérie indépendante responsable du
fln il avait mobilisé ses troupes dans
le bidonville de nanterre
mais l'histoire s'est arrêtée
brutalement ici sur le pont de neuilly à
ce moment là l'étau s'est resserré sur
les algériens la police est à ce
moment-là et prenez des algériens et les
gt à la scène et puis voilà ils vont
charger c'est la peur ils ont tiré et
les housses foutez le camp quoi un petit
muret à l'inca et site se sauver il a
été pris par une rafale est mort et je
suis la seule blessée à l'époque seules
ces images muettes furent diffusés celle
d' arrestations de masse parmi les
trente mille algériens descendus dans
les rues de paris
les photos d'elie kagan elle posé
problème à deux journaux qu'ils ont fusé
la vie catholique un billet sont
formulés à tes photos mais elles vont
choquer mais lecteurs ayvaz fille et un
bon prof en francs mais vu les impôts
publié à france nouvelle ils m'ont dit
elle était restée forte ou non vous
parlez saisir on peut on va essayer ici
si on est cuit michel rôle dans la
journal les autobus de la ratp
réquisitionné avec leur chauffeur emmène
des milliers d' interpeller porte de
versailles
joseph comme un chant gère lui-même
gardiens de la paix préférerais ne pas
s'en souvenir
au fur et à mesure que c'est qu'à
l'arrivée j'étais des charges et manu
militari projetée par faire est frappé
par une double haie de
deux gardiens de la paix qui se disait
comité d'accueil et avait la radio qui
marchait et on disait dans l
arrondissement il ya eu deux tués deux
gardiens de la paix tués dans l autre
cinq tentes et les autres 6 et c'est
donc c'était une intoxication pur de
fashion pour exciter les troupes
plus tard dans la nuit il s'est produit
encore des événements beaucoup plus
tragique 1 puisque une cinquantaine
d'algériens ont été tués alors que
maurice papon était présent à la
préfecture tué puis ensuite leurs corps
ont été jetés à la seine
à l'époque des élus de paris des
sénateurs demandent r&d commission
denquête elles furent toutes refusé
pendant de très longues années un
silence de plomb pesant sur ces
événements trente ans plus tard en 1991
le quid ne parle que de deux morts et 44
blessés
en 1998 on en est à simorre précision
entre parenthèses 200 morts selon le fln
sans doute un minimum la guerre
d'algérie reste une page grise de notre
histoire et pour faire toute la clarté
sur cette manifestation madame trautmann
le ministre de la culture a décidé
d'ouvrir les archives nationales
concernant cet événement avant la date
légale prévue